foreign
foreign
foreign
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilets
and showers
ten times
[Music]
while looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elephants and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
what on Earth is going on with Trump and
toilets
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
[Music]
10 times
[Music]
[Music]
God bless the United States thank you
very much elements of bathrooms well
ladies and gentlemen what a day what a
day as we speak the FBI has raided
Donald Trump's Florida Mar-A-Lago home
of special interest reportedly his
um personal quarters I hope the FBI has
plumbers on staff because they're gonna
need to be plunging that toilet to find
all the documents that this guy has
tried to destroy it it is an incredible
situation I was outside at my home
grilling beautiful sockeye salmon
holding the a baby and then my phone
starts going off and it's even going on
on out producer Pat Mar-A-Lago raided by
FBI
I threw the baby
very quietly and calmly and handed her
to my girlfriend
very calmly got in my car drove to the
studio
and now I'm here and everybody's
completely safe and the baby's fine
um wow we are still trying to figure out
everything that is going on
with Trump's toilet and Trump's personal
quarters the first glimpse of this it
started here on
um well obviously it started where else
than Donald Trump's truth social truth
essential where Donald Trump put out a
release he he released where he says and
I apologize it's sort of hard to see
let's see if I can zoom this somehow
here we go let's see if I can zoom in
okay here we go
uh these are dark times for our nation
as my beautiful home Mar-A-Lago in Palm
Beach Florida is currently Under Siege
raided and occupied by a large group of
FBI agents nothing like this has ever
happened to a president of the United
States before after working and
cooperating with the relevant government
agencies this unannounced raid on my
home was not necessary or appropriate
folks the FBI has executed an
unannounced raid on a former president
you don't do that unless you expect to
find or are worried that Trump might
destroy evidence of criminality
uh it is prosecutorial misconduct it's
not prosecutors the weaponization of the
justice system in an attack by radical
left Democrats who desperately don't
want me to run for president in 24
especially based on recent polls and who
will likewise do anything to stop
Republicans and conservatives in the
upcoming midterm elections such an
assault could only take place in broken
third world countries sadly America has
now become one of those countries
corrupt at a level not seen before they
even broke into my safe look at this
triggered Trump what is the difference
between this and Watergate where
operatives broke into the Democrat
National Committee here in Reverse
Democrats broke into the home of the
45th president of the United States
and then he talks about about Hillary
Hillary Clinton was allowed to delete an
acid wash their acid wash
that's insane 33 000 emails after they
were subpoenaed by Congress nothing
happened to hold her accountable she
even took antique furniture and other
items this is a completely triggered
individual look at Fox News Fox is
despondent over what's going on check
this out
um do we have them
yeah there there is absolutely no
justification Jesse absolutely no just
how does Jason Chaffetz or whoever this
guy is is this Jason Chaffetz how does
this guy know there's no justification
what he doesn't know anything about it
in my experience when the FBI conducts
high-level raids like these they are
planned well in advance every eye is
dotted every T is crossed every X is
slashed
one of the media was give given this
then immediate very large didn't even
report it the president of the United
States a former president United States
has a security clearance oh my God these
people are so triggered I love it I
don't know how I'm going to sleep
tonight these people are so triggered
look at them executive privilege so he
asked it's a word salad Clarence he does
have a skiff he is skiff security
clearance executive privilege media then
you've got to go to court you got to
have a way not be a Banana Republic like
this action is but this is this is the
absolute best oh my God they're losing
it what's Happening Here I want to see
these I want to see Merrick Garland up
there and I want to understand exactly
how in the world they can justify going
in and breaking it into a safe of a
former president of the United States
they have no business doing that none
whatsoever well this this is an
incredible day this is this is truly an
incredible day um don't even wait just
fire him right off the Jump be because
this guy is so corrupt he comes in
cleans up comey's mess with the oh fire
Garland now they're saying what why what
has Garland done well just lets the
whole thing slide then he has agents
cover up what happened with the laptop
remember they didn't even want the
laptop at first then all of a sudden
they got interested in the laptop when
the post was about to break this oh this
is an incredible night guys I I'm so
glad that you're all here to witness
this the right is absolutely
they are frenetically going bonkers
trying to figure out they're throwing
everything this was illegal and immoral
and it violates executive privilege and
classified and fire Garland and free
speech and oh they're gonna throw
everything at the wall now ahead of that
whole division in charge of the
Washington field office
and then yesterday was it last week he
goes on to this hearing in the Senate
and he says I gotta run I got to go I
can't answer any more questions turns
out he takes the FBI jet to his retreat
in the Adirondack oh my God he went on a
vacation so he didn't have to answer any
more questions I don't see how this guy
has any credibility they're completely
unhinged let's see what's happening on
Newsmax Newsmax oh Newsmax look at this
Newsmax has Dick Morris I think a lot of
people would
um justice department declining to make
a comment obviously they did the raid uh
CNN reporting the White House was not
notified about this New York Times says
that this is related to 15 boxes of
materials and we remember the story that
were taken from the National Archives
taken from the White House back in 2021
I guess the materials that came with him
tomorrow White House check the toilets
guys they had better whatever the best
plumber is get Roto-Rooter in there get
Plumbing we need Central Services we
need everybody in there they'd better be
jackhammering I hope they have suction
on whatever they brought so they can
they can figure out what is there what a
day what an incredible day folks welcome
s press has just gifted 50 subscriptions
such an auspicious start I want to say
thanks to Blueberry babe Bert the riot
goat Laura V
uh Thug chukkas mechanically reclaimed
meat queen of wildfire blueberry babe
everybody is dumping in subscriptions
here and it is crazy has the coupon code
indict ever been more relevant than
today
and look at these people using the
coupon code Mike Wade has just signed up
Andrew Lyden just signed up on my
website joinpakman.com putting us at 60.
Jason sickmeyer is gifting subscriptions
on the website people cannot believe
what is happening and we've had the
coupon code for weeks now
we've had the coupon code for we oh look
now they've got Jonathan Turley this is
the guy that they bring on he's the
legal scholar who speaks very soberly
and in a non-partisan way oh right no
he's not okay let's see what he has to
say and ask for a special counsel to be
appointed you know people like Archibald
Cox and others are celebrated because we
appointed a special counsel to look into
Nixon why
it was because we wanted to assure the
American people oh give me so now the
line is going to be
they should have done it right with a
special counsel
they did that they did and before we
knew anything about the special counsel
Fox was 24 7. it's a Witch Hunt now
Turley wants to pretend well if they had
just done it with a special counsel then
we would have it would have been fine
because it's due process and it would
have been perfect
they tried it and you do you say that
the special counsel is is not okay
these people are unbelievable let's see
if Trump has added anything else to his
truth sensual
um let's zoom out here that an hour ago
he announced the raid
nothing new since then
okay we're still standing by on truth
but it is quite a situation here quite a
situation
um oh Kevin Taylor as well as the blah
have just gifted
five subscriptions each on YouTube
putting us at 71. oak on the hill and
manoli and koyani and Trisha Northstar
have just signed up on Twitch Prime and
then guitar goddess has gifted five
subscriptions
wow people are excited here super chats
dumping in Trump is telling Fox hit him
with everything you got us rhinos are
about to trample Trump grab your popcorn
Greg with a ten thousand
what is cop what I'm not sure what
currency that is Trump complaining about
being the most persecuted in history he
deserves to be I hope the Alex Jones
texts reveal more 100 100 sir please add
Roto-Rooter as a coupon code if they are
not deeply Plumbing Trump's toilet
they're not gonna find everything I
really hope that the FBI thought ahead
and called a plumber
I want to say thanks to Andrew Burch for
signing up at joinpakman.com folks the
coupon code is indict because that's the
direction we need to be going that's
where we need to be going
I don't know that we are but we need to
be going that way thanks to zelgeth for
gifting five subscriptions on YouTube
let's look at some news reports Trump
says FBI conducting search of Mar-A-Lago
estate look at this guy
former president Trump said in a lengthy
statement Monday that the FBI was
conducting a search of his Mar-A-Lago
estate
Zoom it out a little
the circumstances were not immediately
clear justice department spokesperson
Dina Iverson said there was no comment
after working and cooperating with the
relevant government agencies this
unannounced raid on my home was not
necessary or appropriate
the justice department has been
investigating the discovery of boxes of
Records containing classified
information taken to Mar-A-Lago after
the presidency ended
it was referred to justice department
which said it found 15 boxes dumps of
envelopes and folders and documents
federal law bars the removal of
classified documents to unauthorized
locations Trump could argue that he is
the ultimate declassification Authority
it was not clear whether the FBI search
was connected to that probe we really
don't know that much about this yet CNN
also reporting
FBI executes search warrant this is all
based on Trump's say so
Trump was not in Florida at the time of
the raid justice department has declined
to comment White House has declined to
comment CNN has reached out to the FBI
for comment
wow wow wow
what a day
Trump FBI raid was prosecutorial
misconduct we are monitoring Fox News
and we are monitoring Newsmax they're
both losing their minds over what's
going on and it just sound wonderful
Dick Morris thank you for joining us
tonight great Insight on all this we
appreciate it we're going to continue to
follow the breaking news coming out of
Mar-A-Lago
South Florida
we'll be right back
all right
so Newsmax monitoring all of it very
very closely and we still don't know the
full explanation as to what and why is
going on here we just don't know yet but
it doesn't sound very good for Donald
Trump
uh I wanted to oh let me pull up another
thing here
I want to see what other triggered
commentaries
we are seeing all over the internet
Jesse Waters immediately calling it an
election Ploy oh let's check that out
this is gonna absolutely enrage the
country especially the Republican base a
base that is clearly behind the
ex-president you look at the CPAC straw
poll dominating it you look at the straw
poll they did for the Turning Point
event he dominated it he is clearly the
front runner to seize the Republican
nomination and polling now shows that
he's going to defeat Joe Biden in 2024
if that's the match-up so to then send
FBI agents we assume this is Eric
Garland it's not even clear the F that
the White House knew this was happening
right now maybe I mean it the White
House may have known it's not clear
right now the White House even knew this
was happening and somehow it was
Democrats who sent the FBI everything
being stated here is completely without
evidence
the department of just Joe Biden's
attorney general to send FBI agents to
Mar-A-Lago to the home of the president
oh God you know before a midterm
election in the run-up to a presidential
election this guy is he has no idea what
he's talking about people are flushing
toilets 10 times 15 times that's true
now we know why
uh look at this father Frank Pavone a
religion he's clergy guys we've got to
be respectful because he's clergy even
though he's a right-wing bomb thrower
the FBI has just committed the most
shameful act that agency has ever done
in all of American History by a totally
baseless politically motivated raid on
Trump's home it is a threat to all of us
and it's time for this crap to stop
trying to steal an election you didn't
win
and taking 15 boxes of documents to your
house to me is a greater threat than
anything I know about this raid so far
okay
if you have a different perspective you
let me know
Dan bongino apparently says the left
thinks this is hilarious
I mean yeah I think it's hilarious and I
think it's great
I just want to say in closing listen
America they're laughing at you the left
thinks this is hilarious if you doubt me
just go to any other goofy platforms
Twitter else will write out they think
this is hilarious well yeah
I mean of course it's hilarious this guy
spent four years flouting not flaunting
look it up the word is flouting flouting
every presidential norm and check and
balance he's gotten away scot-free
and now the FBI is at his house
hopefully sucking up whatever he flushed
down his toilet
it's absolutely hilarious and it also
seems eminently appropriate eminently
appropriate folks we are doing
everything we can here to keep up with
the various messages and things coming
in truth social has been going crazy and
it's incredible oh let's get back over
to truth social let's see if Trump
posted again
he hasn't let's see at home
I don't even know what I should be
looking for here
like I don't even know how this how this
works
oh Dinesh is calling to have the FBI
abolished didn't Trump select the
current FBI director
now they want the FBI completely
abolished so they want to get rid of the
Department of Education they want to get
rid of the FBI okay
I think I need to be following more
people here for us to really get the
full scope
uh but if there's specific funny
triggerings there oh look now they've
got Buck Sexton I'm sure here's gonna
give us the truth on what's going on
took for example by hand but the
threshold for actually sending people in
under the threat of force effectively
the FBI comes in with guns and says
we're coming into your home one way or
another that's extraordinary so what
could possibly be at issue here that it
would make this level of FBI involvement
in any way Justified not only legally
but you have to look at politically a
guy who worked for the CIA and has no
idea about anything that's going on is
casting doubt onto what was done well
maybe we wait for the facts to come out
right illusion find an area of criminal
law and at some point or rather they've
made a false case against Trump that has
gone nowhere are we really to believe
that now on the retention of classified
documents they finally got him are we
really to believe that at this point in
time Donald Trump after everything else
were they either fabricated evidence
they lied they smeared look at these
allegations
they they must have fabricated evidence
give me a break you gotta give me a
break uh oh hold on my twitch
subscription thing is like off the side
there we go 1475. thank you to Beth
Graham for the twitch Prime subscription
putting us at 87. folks if there has
ever been a day to sign up on my website
with the coupon code indict to get an
ungodly discount it's today as the FBI
has raided Trump's Mar-A-Lago they're in
his personal quarters they've reportedly
jacked open his safe and we don't know
but hopefully they brought plumbers to
try to figure out what Trump may have
flushed let me thank the following
people who just signed up on my website
Nathan Williams is a new member
jamalyn manorino
Jay Malin I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly Sherry Cochran Neil Jarrett
and Thomas Rivers have all just signed
up on my website you can also gift
memberships on the website Juan has
gifted one Stanley minarik has gifted
one Kevin May sends a gift Stanley
minarik sends another one if you would
like a free membership to my website you
get the bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money never
somebody else that makes money to find
themselves as bad right you get the
bonus show which Alex Jones hates you
get a dedicated feed
six hours before everybody else you get
the membership every day okay uh you get
the the show every day with a membership
use the coupon code indict everybody
gets a thank you hopefully the website
doesn't go down because it's under
extremely heavy pressure right now
extremely heavy pressure
some people have voicemail thoughts
about what's going on let me see if I
can play any of them
hi David bill from North Carolina
frequent viewer audio is a disaster
audio is a disaster so I can't do it
hey David it's a beautiful day uh I feel
like
it's it's funny that everything
Republicans were warned of and even
warned themselves of happening if they
elected Trump just all coming exact like
completely true like
they were they needed to expect this
they could they should have expected
this it was so obvious
and uh it's just it's sweet wow wow wow
wow people are going absolutely Wild
oh my God Whitney is calling and she I
think she's on topic for once Whitney is
on topic Deepak I cannot handle this
they're writing Mar-A-Lago right now I
can't handle it it's it's just too it's
too enough
oh my gosh you have to cover this it's
so phenomenal Justice oh you know what I
actually don't think that's is that
Whitney I don't even know that that is
Whitney that might not be Whitney
probably happening question mark is this
real are we really doing this no this is
not Whitney this is someone else who's
really excited FBI is over there
they've been talking about how they got
into his safe
the Elation of this caller about what's
going on
is absolutely perfect
oh God guys there's a Fox News Alert now
look at this hour ago we learned that
the Biden Administration raided the home
of the former president Donald Trump in
Palm Beach Florida Donald Trump
announced the raid in a statement and
Fox News has confirmed that the raid
occurred quote these are dark times for
our Nations at the former president as
my beautiful home Mar-A-Lago in Palm
Beach Trump might face consequences it's
very very dangerous a large group of FBI
agents Trump wrote nothing like this has
ever happened to a president of the
United States before right Trump said
the raid which was unannounced amounts
to quote prosecutorial misconduct the
weaponization of the general Trump's a
lawyer so he would know attack by the
radical left Democrats who desperately
do not want me to run for president in
2024 especially based on recent polls
Trump said agents also broke into his
safe that's the best former president
Donald Trump concluded his statement
noting that Hillary Clinton quote was
allowed to delete an acid wash 33 000
emails imagine being a fox clown and
having to read the acid wash thing
wow in New York Times is reporting
tonight that the search is quote focused
on material that Mr Trump had brought
with him to Mar-A-Lago his private club
in Residence
at the White House those boxes allegedly
contained many pages of classified
documents according to a person familiar
with their contents the times continued
quote Mr Trump you know Trump's story is
he organized the return of all of the
documents to the National Archives so
then there certainly wouldn't be
anything in the safe right I mean that
would just be logical Taz confirmed that
per standard protocol FBI director Ray
and attorney general Garland were aware
of the raid before it occurred however
you characterized what happened in the
United States of America today this is a
defining moment a seminal moment a
partisan moment one that Generations
will look back on and ask was this a
moment we broke apart the FBI led by the
guy Trump selected has done something
very partisan he asked tonight was there
an evidentiary basis was there a legal
basis or was this a partisan Witch Hunt
to begin by Trump's FBI director Mike
Emanuel who is standing by with the
latest Mike well good evening Fox News
guys this is the absolute best
this this is unbelievable these people
are losing their minds and I love it
tiege asks a good question via Super
Chat could Obama have been involved
Obama it's possible
Graham Leslie just gifted five YouTube
memberships guys let's go for 200. I
want to say thanks to Sam the sleaze bag
420x weed bung Meg's dollar batteries
champagne shots real Tom G fear of hats
and mobsta for the twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at 109
and I must thank the incredible people
who are dumping memberships in on our
website I don't know that the website
can handle it Jean-Paul LaFlamme
Alexander laminen Nathan Quimby Greg
Roth
Ray s Tyler McAllister Judy eckies
Michael barsano Kevin zavatsky Sean
Rafferty Sophie brunette bulvin rumal
rondawa
Scott Curtis wow this is crazy
Jerry atkisson Nancy lowinger Phyllis
Gentry have all signed up on my website
that is 15 putting us at 124 and people
are gifting subscriptions like they're
going out of stock Desiree Delong sends
a gifted subscription stage presence
Gareth hardrays Williams
thank you very much I appreciate that
the coupon code is indict and it's in
diet for a very special reason
other super chats coming in this is the
next step down the dark path the lies
January 6th now media Outlets telling
Their audience exactly what will
increase the passion in polarization we
are on the path towards what we fear
oh there's a real chance that the fox
and Newsmax coverage of this is going to
fire up people who are willing to do
violence that's absolutely a risk that
is absolutely a risk because they have
such an audience
on a serious note do you think Trump's
safe will need elements of Medico
will Kane is such a disappointment these
days and I think to think I thought he
was an okay guy at ESPN I didn't know
him from ESPN to be perfectly Frank
Benoit binge watched The Man in the High
Castle if you want to see the timeline
the U.S is currently in excellent show
I hope the FBI is paying the plumbing
division overtime for the big massive
dumps of evidence they're collecting I
know believe me I mentioned that I
mentioned that people in the audience
are so fired up
um let's see what people have to say
here
hey David thank you so much for taking
my message I gotta say I hope that the
Patriots at the FBI I mean FBI plumber
division are getting paid overtime for
the hard work that they're doing in
terms of getting all the flush material
from oh you gotta check it flushing
toilets 10 times 15 times absolutely
Melody calling in
hey David my name is Melody Hernandez
it is so about time this is something
that should happen a long time ago a
long time ago and he's been out running
his mouth and he's getting cut with his
pants down
hooray this is one of the biggest leaps
for us people are elated about what's
going on I think maybe the most
beautiful part is that it's happening to
the person
who's been saying and still says to lock
up Hillary
Hillary Clinton
oh guys Stephen Miller look at this
nation you have the sitting president of
the United States Joe Biden through his
justice department through his FBI
conducting a raid there is no evidence
at this time that Biden even knew about
it never mind orchestrated it and also
the 45th president of the United States
as president Trump pointed out in his
statement
it is risable that this would be
purportedly done in the name of document
preservation from the leaks we've seen
when Hillary Clinton used an off book
server for years to conduct clap so did
half of trump staff at the same time
money was being funneled by the millions
into the Clinton Foundation I have never
seen Miller this triggered he's
basically putting together an ink blot
of conspiracy theories by the
eye we are truly living in a situation
where the FBI has become a praetorian
guard from Rome where they take it unto
themselves to decide who wields power in
this country
you know Stephen I can't help but notice
that for all that Trump was accused it
seems that Biden is intent on embodying
it was said right they should have
raided Biden's basement where he ran his
campaign from there's an idea wow they
don't even know what to say they're
running interference but they're running
it in the sloppiest way I can imagine
and by the way if I were Stephen Miller
I'd be worried is this getting close to
me at this point in time
welcome if you're just joining us
Mar-A-Lago has been raided by the FBI
they're reportedly in Trump's personal
quarters they've reportedly opened his
safe
we don't know the full scope and
everything about this let's listen to
CNN government about this or his
attorneys I should say that he believes
that this raid was conducted unfairly
the search warrant was conducted
unfairly because he says after working
and cooperating with the relevant
government agencies this unannounced
raid on my home was not necessary or
appropriate we should note that they are
had about 15 documents 15 boxes of
documents and we were told that they had
delayed in actually sending them back to
the National Archives until it became
clear that action could be taken and
then those documents were sent back so
still a lot of details that we don't
know but this is quite a remarkable job
so Norm what Caitlyn just said there
according to Trump there had been
discussions between his people and
investigators about the archives
what step or or what line would have
been crossed in your mind and again
there's so much we don't know and people
need to know that we're going to be
perfectly transparent about what we
don't know here but in your mind what
lie would have need to be in Cross for
the FBI for perhaps Merrick Garland if
he was going to approve this for this
raid to have taken place well uh you
always have to have the probable cause
to believe that a crime or crimes we're
committed you always have to have
judicial approval but when it comes to a
former president that that hurdle is
even higher John so I think there would
need to be a showing of uh probable
cause that not only were documents
removed but that it happened repeatedly
that not only were they I have to tell
you guys like I am completely open to
the possibility that nothing will come
of this if we find out the FBI did
something wrong I will criticize the FBI
whatever
it's oh god look they're doing the
toilet oh you got to be kidding me
they're doing the toilet people are
flushing toilets it's times 15 times I
can't believe they're putting that up
big man
big dumps yeah
um my instinct is they probably had
their T's crossed and eyes dotted I mean
guys CNN has a picture of a toilet up
there they're the story involves toilets
uh uh it is an incredible incredible 8 8
22 a day we will all remember that is
for damn sure I have to say thank you to
S Perez who just dumped 50 additional
memberships on Twitch and has now surged
into third place all time
in gifted subscriptions with 420.
Skittles stew still in first place with
603
a huge huge dump not to be flushed of
memberships thanks also to Lynette for
the twitch Prime subscription I know
that there are people signing up on my
website and I haven't thanked them yet
let me do that now Jennifer einolf is a
new member on my website Patsy Hartman
is a new member Bryce gilpatrick has
signed up Andy Claudio is a new member
Nadine Meadows welcome Nadine Colin
Schmidt just signed up Melanie Savage
and chestina
Turner
Joey D and Lauren Smith as well as
Sheila Larkey and Charlotte Schulte all
signing up on my website that is 12
putting us at 190. folks this is the day
the coupon code is indict use the code
it's never been more relevant than today
you can sign up at joinpakman.com also
thanks to people gifting memberships
like Lisa Rader who just gifted a
membership on my website
number 191. let's see what people are
saying over on YouTube Sue Fox with a 50
Super Chat oh my God I want to buy my
brother a membership since he is a huge
crumps trumpster this is too good it
really is
I believe Trump will go live on Newsmax
telephone tonight don't you well we're
monitoring it
we're my they're talking about Joe
Biden's treasonous dealings right now so
you know they may be a little bit
preoccupied there
remember when Louis Gomer got upset that
they can no longer lie to the FBI I do
remember them
David sir the doj must ensure something
serious occurs because the right wing
will be violent Trump must now go all
the way down it's all or nothing I know
what you mean
I find it hilarious this happened right
after the January 6 committee requested
Alex Jones text messages I know the
timing is funny I don't believe that
there's a correlation there
the FBI gave my mom a better birthday
present than mine today well said Joe
well said
what if this convinces the trumpist to
actually vote while the Democrats become
complacent I don't believe that will
happen
I don't believe that will happen I want
to say an incredible thank you to S
Perez who just dumped in 100 additional
twitch memberships
an incredible number
also want to say thanks to huge the huge
Kenny's prog rock jukebox two shoes and
zandig for the twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at 295
and over on the website thank you to
Frank Craven
who just signed up on my website and
also a big thank you to Stanley minarik
and Mitchell sulkowski each gifting a
subscription that puts us at 298.
the super chats are continuing to dump
in Megan says apparently there's a
conspiracy theory that Alex Jones is
actually comedian big hick comedian Bill
Hicks
that I have not heard
let's hear from more people in the
audience leaving voicemails
hi David uh big night for you love the
show long time washer
uh I think it's [ __ ] hilarious how
Fox News will not even take a second to
describe why the FBI might be conducting
a raid on the logo I know that part
stands out the most for me anyway it's
unbelievable goodbye thank you very much
I appreciate that very very much uh
we're getting notifications that some of
our Alex Jones videos are being
demonetized on uh YouTube that's
interesting we'll look more deeply into
that tomorrow if you're just joining us
it is an incredible day oh they brought
on the former AG we've got to hear this
the criminal investigation of Donald
Trump and that obviously is a big step
and you know both of them uh you know
fearing for their future you know are
probably have some measure of conflict
in the situation but a typical
investigation an agent can go to a
supervisor you know tell them what they
has and make sure that there are
reasonable investigative steps that can
be taken based on an initial predication
of that case obviously in concert with a
prosecutor like a U.S attorney's office
but you know this type of case where
you're going after a former president
United States and possibly future
president United States would involve
the attorney general and the FBI
director and and Senior officials at the
highest levels so I'm going to ask you
to speculate here Matt you can decline
if you would like but I'm going to ask
you to speculate you know we've listened
to Chris Ray over the last several weeks
or so in in the last week at the very
least testified before Congress about
the resources of the FBI where and where
he could not dedicate resources we heard
him asked about the hunter Biden
investigation the Gretchen Whitmer
investigation against violence against
pro-life Advocates and or pro-abortion
Advocates of pro-life Sinners he talked
about essentially Matt the limited
resources of the FBI and therefore
prosecutorial discretion in where they
choose to put their resources is is
there anything more important than
holding a former president accountable
if they committed crimes why in your
estimation what is this about is this
about supposed classified documents is
this about January 6th why is this at
the top of their list of priorities well
will that's a great question and
obviously what you prioritize you put
resources is towards and if you had many
FBI agents at Mar-A-Lago today that took
away from other things that those uh oh
now they're acting like it's not what
was going on at Mar-A-Lago wasn't
important so that the agents were
distracted from other cases the these
people are going to throw everything at
the wall everything at the wall
to see what sticks unbelievable stuff
people very very fired up in the Super
chats Karma's coming for Trump while Fox
scrambles it's possible a good chunk of
the GOP would relish charges in a
conviction you know that's a very good
point there are definitely people in the
Republican party that are sick and tired
of trump sick and absolutely tired of
trump
but they don't feel like they can really
act on it because Trump still pulls well
in the Republican party I think that
that's quite an astute statement I think
so
um let's see what else we have here
let's keep calm it could take weeks or
months to get to the bottom of this of
course of course
how perfect it's the anniversary of the
date Nixon resigned
is that true
let's see date of Nixon resignation
August 8 1974 well said Marjorie it's
8-8
as soon as I saw your live notification
says Vin I ran to my dad with tears in
my eyes and I told him sir and we were
both so elated to find out thanks for
stopping your day to cover this yeah if
you're just joining me I was having a
beautiful evening I was out grilling
some sockeye salmon and broccolini
broccolini I would argue one of the best
vegetables that that's out there I was
holding my newborn daughter my phone
starts blowing up it's mar-a-lago's been
raided I tossed the baby 20 feet to my
girlfriend got right in my car avoided
10 people in gas powered pickup trucks
trying to run my electric vehicle on the
road to get to the studio and made it
onto the air
true story true story and that's how we
ended up here today which was really
really remarkable
um okay I I know I'm falling behind on
thanking people thanks to on Twitch the
old tired Road pizza man alicaz
crunkwell I spaghetti typical bad
uh okay
that's it that puts us at 304 on the
website the website is about to crash I
think from how many people are signing
up with the coupon code indict welcome
to Evelyn McFarland Larry Shaw Declan
golden
as well as Thomas Ricci Lisa carpenito
Kenneth Hardwick is a new member Audrey
whitco welcome Ross voce
William Bailey and Kenneth Goodwin have
signed up
Katherine Jennings is a new member
and
um Alice Jenna
and Susie Kirkpatrick thank you to all
of you for signing up for memberships
that's 12 12 and 304 that looks like it
would be 316. also people gifting
memberships on the website Sean Irwin
Adam Becker
Adam Becker gifting another one Joe
Rader with a gift
that's four gifted subscriptions does
anybody want a free membership because
you can fill out the very simple form at
davidpackman.com
slash free membership to request a free
membership and then very importantly
Xavier
signing up via twitch and 100 gifted
subscriptions from s press dumping in s
Prez must be now into second place at
minimum in terms of gifted subscriptions
ever
the voicemails are pouring in pouring in
hey David
um I just got a tweet or a direct
message from Marjorie Taylor green she
said that it's actually antifa and BLM
that's rating Trump's Mar-A-Lago that
could be that actually could be yeah
let's see what else we have here people
are just losing it
oh my God David this is Judy from New
Jersey I have been I'm a watcher for a
long time I just got a membership but oh
my God I am over the last few weeks with
the January 6th of Alex Jones and you
know Manning and all the others getting
finally getting nailed this is like oh
my God I sat down started looking around
I'm like what right what oh my God I'm
so excited please do that TV please guys
nail these guys I'm sorry so Judy's very
very excited now folks I got to say
something I'm seeing a bunch of emails
in my inbox asking for free memberships
I'm only gonna say it once
emailing is not how you get a free
membership I already said you go to
davidpackman.com free membership you
don't need to email me I can't help you
by email if you want a free membership
you go to davidpackman.com free
membership okay do not email do not
email me do not email me or the show do
not send any emails about a free
membership it's just davidpackman.com
free membership you put your name in and
we have a system okay it goes in order
now we have learned that Donald Trump is
not at Mar-A-Lago today Donald Trump is
in New York City
and so now
the live shots are moving to Trump Tower
and it's at least conceivable that maybe
Trump is going to make some kind of a
statement we are monitoring CNN
we are monitoring Fox News we are
monitoring Newsmax which is running
commercials for
um
some kind of a phone caption system okay
that's okay we're we're monitoring other
things
let's see what else is on people's minds
here
um
let's see from Caitlin hi David this is
Caitlin from Florida
um I just logged onto your screen
um
yeah look
there's stream here
what is going on
have you ever
dealt with the word live through a
scandal like this I mean what what's the
last thing you can think of that we
should
I mean the Trump Riot day is the last
thing that was like this sadly like this
I mean I'm gonna be able to stop until
my grandkids that I remember when the
January 6th Insurrection happened and I
remember when the rate has happened
right
okay that's the end of the voicemail
very very interesting
you know I don't know that if if there
are adult diapers at Mar-A-Lago I don't
know that that's necessarily going to be
something we find out about
um
yeah I I don't I'm just not sure about
that
holy cow sir
you know Fox News may be going nuts
right now and running interference
and I wonder if we're going to see
Rupert Murdoch bring them in now hmm
because Rupert Murdoch
to abandon Trump
yeah I mean that's it's a fair question
hey David if you look on pillows truth
essential account it looks like people
in the comments are already trying to
start up some kind of action and a plan
to meet to get together so check it out
nice all right so here it is Mike pillow
you guys know Mike pillow right we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines over 54 countries have now been
taken by the machines exactly that guy
he posted Trump's statement let's see
what people are saying
uh
action today raid will be met with swift
action FBI Burning Midnight Oil
it's time this is it we must get serious
this must be stopped the life as we have
known does not exist as of today August
8 is when everything changed now every
one of us uh oh
God this is exactly what I was afraid of
we need to meet and plan out what needs
to be done
we have to pick a location and date
uh oh
this is not good
these people
can become extremely violent as we saw
on January 6th
wow
wow
hmm
we're under siege it's called communism
abolish the FBI wow
wow wow
yes so these people are these people
it's oh it's Lara Trump let's listen do
to
Duty these uh documents that have been
in question have been everybody's been
cooperating everybody from my
father-in-law's team has been
cooperating with the FBI with any
Authority so there's been an
investigation to cooperate with that's
interesting no need to make such a big
scene to do something this insane quite
frankly
um to a former president but I think
everybody clearly knows will what is
going on here this is about weaponizing
the justice system as it has been so
many times in the past against somebody
who you politically do not like they
detest Donald Trump not just on the
Democrat side but the general
establishment because he's not one of
them because he doesn't play their game
he's a victim fundamentally not a
perpetrator that he's running for
president in 2024 and this is a very
convenient way to just throw a little
more mud on Donald Trump as though they
haven't already done enough this is the
same agency don't forget the FBI who you
know had falsified documents to get fisa
warrants to you know conduct this entire
sham Russia hoax that the country had to
deal with for two years millions of
taxpayer dollars in our time that will
never get back to find what absolutely
nothing they've been trying to shove
January 6 down everybody's throat right
in an effort to get people to care about
that and think that's the most important
thing in the world that hasn't worked
for them yet so here they are heading
into a midterm and heading into a
presidential election she's acting like
Democrats did this what a delusional
situation Mark Elias I'm being told via
Super Chat tweeted something interesting
uh
the media is missing the really really
big reason why the raid today is a
potential Blockbuster in American
politics Mark Elias is pointing to 18
U.S code 2071. concealment removal or
mutilation generally
this is something which if you are found
guilty of if you look at subsection B
shall forfeit his office and be
disqualified from holding any office
under the United States it is
conceivable based on legal analyst Mark
Elias
that what is being investigated here in
connection with this raid could
disqualify Donald Trump from ever being
president again
that is interesting
in fact I should probably bookmark that
and send it to myself for tomorrow's
show because this is this story might
make the show tomorrow I don't know it
just it might we'll have to wait and see
thanks to deeper shades of house as well
as DJ Newell Lil chunk gaming
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 424 folks the website is
getting crushed there's 166 people right
now trying to get memberships wait no
it's 155. I want to say thank you to the
following people who just signed up on
my website let's go through these
Crystal Hendricks Brenda gronstedge
Steve Randall Johanna Lee Barnett
Barnett Christine Becker
Michelle Pearson Anna Gerhart
Kimberly Ranka Darren Porter and Pam
Cason
many of these folks using the coupon
code indict on this special day Dan
Haviland Sarah Hagee and Donald
Patterson
Darren Parker is a new member Matt
Mulholland and Stanley westerveld
welcome to lorianne frewing and David
Ellis also welcome to Don Williams
Christy Luna Charlie Uribe and John
Purdy welcome to all of you that is 21
putting us at 4 45 also thanks to
everybody who's been gifting memberships
that includes Stanley minarik as well as
Stephen Hart
Jerry Musselman
appreciate all of you as well
that puts us at 4 48 and one last
straggler here that I missed thanks to
Terry Thomas for signing up at
joinpakman.com it is a shocking and
appalling day s Perez has just done
dumped in I hope as Perez can afford
this stuff another 100 memberships on
Twitch
and I also want to say thanks to music
by Stanley Green Man the freak and baby
Cadbury Cadbury
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 553 the record for
memberships ever is 605 in a day and we
are within Striking Distance of that
Steve Bannon on the phone listen to this
on the justice department and get to the
bottom of who approved this this is this
is so outrageous
no I want to ask you this question Steve
um you know I'm familiar with um I'm
familiar with your point of view I'm
familiar with the opinions you share on
war room I'm familiar with how deep you
fear the corruption has run within the
United States of America I'm curious I
said this earlier in the program
believing elections can change the the
place in which we sit today United
States of America is a very optimistic
point of view because this corruption if
it is partisan corruption isn't
relegated to the FBI we saw 87 000 new
IRS agents have been hired you can look
at almost any Federal Institution
including intelligence Community who
dismissed Hunter Biden's laptop is
disinformation and you can say to
yourself this isn't one these people are
like sped up now trying to figure out
how to deal with this election our
problem is deeper
100 correct this is not about corruption
the list this is about the
administrative State this is about an
undemocratic human status bigger than
the oxy this is the administrative State
and they want to run things their own
way and they want to pick and choose who
who Ed runs and who actually wins this
is why
there's one we have two-thirds of the
Nations and back of us Hispanics
African-Americans Asian Americans that's
a lie take control of the House of
Representatives with an overwhelming
Victory and then act like we mean right
the Jim Jordans and people have to step
up and Kevin McCarthy have to step up
and say we're gonna have full
investigations we're going to choke them
down incorporation listen we I got it
Steve this is a democratic okay go ahead
I hate to cut you off Steve we have uh
we have more information coming in as we
speak so I got to get to that it's great
to hear from you tonight thank you for
your time
all right this is the Fox News Alert
Donald Trump said tonight his Mar-A-Lago
home is under siege by FBI agents A
source tells Fox News that agents are
indiscriminately removing items from the
residents indiscriminating the
president's son Eric Trump spoke to our
own Brian Kilmeade and told him as many
as 30 agents raided the former
president's Palm Beach home oh look at
the fox says mike Emanuel is joining us
again with the absolute latest Mike Will
good evening sources familiar tell Fox
News this FBI raid a former president
Trump's Palm Beach home is related to
The Taking of potential classified
information from the White House upon
leaving office January 20th of last year
the National Archives says there were 15
boxes that contained what it believed to
be presidential records noting they must
be preserved a source familiar tells Fox
FBI agents went to Mar-A-Lago looking at
every single office in the President's
Day safe and grab documents and boxes
without reviewing them there on property
The Source telling Fox they took boxes
and documents to review once they left
Mar-A-Lago and were told they were not
being judicious about what they took fox
has learned former president Trump I
mean often the FBI takes everything New
York City when he learned the raid was
taking place in Florida the former
president saying in his public statement
they broke his safe and obviously he was
quite upset with the raid taking place
well
all right Mike thank you there for this
might have been a perfect raid now the
president of the United States the
former president of the United States
home in Mar-A-Lago has been raided by
FBI agents upwards of 30 agents broke
into a safe took boxes of documents away
not discovering them not going through
them on premises but taking them away
for further analysis we do not have
information at this time as to why what
is the legal or evidentiary basis as to
what is the investigation in the raid
into Donald Trump but for now we turn to
Fox's Shannon bream for a legal analysis
of the situation unfolding tonight what
an extraordinary situation I mean truly
an extraordinary situation I know the
audience is completely titillated
uh let's listen
hey David uh I think it's hilarious
Trump is getting raided but do you think
um he'll ever actually be prosecuted if
anything and okay so that's really the
question now I would love for people to
let me know in the chat
this is great and the triglies are now
showing up at Mar-A-Lago to demonstrate
their support they've crossed out pence
from Trump Pence this is growing and we
may soon have crowds starting to form in
various places okay let me know in the
chat
is Trump getting indicted
what do you think let me know in the
chat is Trump getting indicted
um
FBI seized over 1 000 packets of ketchup
exactly
exactly very very well said
the F the panda
has
um signed up via twitch Prime
and S Perez just dumped in another 100
twitch Prime subscriptions putting us at
654 we have never seen a number like
this s Prez is now the top gifter of
subscriptions ever with 830 putting
Skittle stew well over 200 memberships
below that I want to say thanks to
Cinder Soul who has sent three gifts I'm
scruffy and Alina
who have also signed up via twitch Prime
and I must thank our website members who
are signing up by the truckloads Sheree
Hudgins is a new member aurelian ekoto
Ian Barrett is a new member
Donna gilland has signed up Patrick
Bolin Marco Lara Robbie Pike has signed
up
Jennifer Classen Michael Colcord is a
new member so is Brenda dorenfeld I want
to say thank you to Colin Adler Lane
Joel Smith and Nicholas
in a tank show I hope I'm not butchering
that horribly I really appreciate all of
your support that's 12 putting us at 671
does patreon count double today
absolutely any pledges on our patreon
Today patreon.com davidpackman Show they
will count as two William Bailey just
made a pledge on our patreon and we're
counting it double
let's see what else is on folks Minds as
an average Republican might say when
speaking of people of color if he has
nothing to hide why would he object to a
search I think that's eminently
reasonable as a question for sure
um 18 USC 2071 we did look at that
statute recently
if Trump is disqualified in 22 says Sean
isn't that bad for Democrats since it
effectively hands DeSantis the
Republican primary ticket it may work
out that well listen we have to just go
step by step and follow the evidence
right now there was enough evidence for
the raid to be conducted
we will then look at what comes after
that okay we can only take it step by
step
couple other voicemails these are just
dumping in
hey David it's Frank from Florida
as I've been telling you for the last
six or eight months this guy's a stone
criminal yep
so
hopefully they find some some evidence
in the house if not
this will definitely uh
cause an uprising right
right I don't disagree with that
I think it's completely plausible
hey David real quick how do you think
Rhonda Santos feels about this uh FBI
raid
um that's uh currently going on at
Mar-A-Lago probably happened you think
he's happy about it do you think he's
just you know surprised or I'm just
curious I think he probably is Happy
folks a crowd is very quickly starting
to gather we are seeing Trump Flags we
are seeing let's go Brandon this crowd
has materialized extremely quickly
before our very eyes we are starting to
see a police presence in Palm Beach
Florida it seems as though there is some
kind of perverted reverse vigil taking
place
uh outside of Trump's Mar-A-Lago
and uh
uh wow I'm told that Reuters live also
has video of that let me take a look at
that
Reuters
uh live how do I even find that
Reuters uh here it is
oh boy okay just from the honking you
already know it's gonna get a little
wacky
so here it is a crowd starting to gather
at Mar-A-Lago let's see if we can listen
to the sweet nothings they're shouting
folks the trumpists are extremely
triggered and they are starting to stack
up all around Mar-A-Lago uh showing a
sign of support for
um and oh whoa look at this oh boy this
could get it this could end up getting
quite ugly actually
oh no
I don't think this is going to end
anytime soon the golf carts are out
which you know is a big big thing for a
lot of the folks down there
um wow wow wow wow I want to say thanks
to the slithy toads
Renny baby
socialist dragon
Let's Get Physical Paco Taco J Chad
moden the real Andrew Mays discarded for
real
and blueberry babe all of whom just
grabbed or gifted subscriptions folks
the golf cart is out the golf cart is
out
people signing up on my website Angus
Atkins criminal Tiffany van Hove Tiffany
mclea Paul Burgess
Derek Goodwin
uh uh I can't thank all of you folks
enough for the support today that's five
putting us at 685
antiaro just made a patreon pledge and
those count double today and then people
gifting subscriptions include Rachel
Sims as well as stennett for Senate
um Martin Fillion
I believe that that's it oh Sean
Heffernan also gifting subscriptions
which is just unbelievable what is
taking place here unbelievable the
trumpists are arriving the trumpists are
triggered and they are showing up
DeSantis would have known an FBI rate in
Florida would have been imminent why
didn't he warn Trump I don't know that
that's true at all
I don't know that that's true
Centrist Pacman is afraid of criticism
and doesn't allow dissent on his channel
uh I'm a leftist and everybody's allowed
to say what they want as long as they
aren't personal attacks or you know
um uh penises made out of parentheses
and ampersands all right so hope that
was worth five bucks for you it's the
end of the world of we as we know it and
I feel fine says Mark Fillion
um okay there is now a helicopter
presence arriving in Palm Beach all
right let me get reset I didn't realize
this was going to be such a long or wide
stream so let me get reset with my water
and snacks we're gonna listen to the Fox
news coverage and I'm going to be back
in five he said he didn't know anything
about the Ukrainian whistleblower just
as he lied about the Russia collusion
hoax this is the chairman of the
intelligence committee with oversight of
the FBI it is really quite frightening
how do you explain it Miranda how do you
explain the the devotion of resources to
this to what we're watching unfold today
and tonight and the total lack of a
devotion of resources and that really
doesn't do it justice because the FBI
didn't just decline to investigate
Hunter Biden they spun it as
disinformation so how do you explain
that disparity
well it it just shows the politicization
of the FBI and under a completely weak
uh director a Christopher Ray who was um
you know one of Donald Trump's worst
Personnel choices uh if the FBI is
completely out of control it's a number
of uh you know different field offices
that are their own fiefdoms God knows
what they're up to some of these
particularly the Washington DC office
which seems to have carriage for this
current raid a hundred FBI agents
raiding the home of the former president
uh potential future presidential
candidate it is incredible as you have
had people say it is unprecedented and
it's really frightening because the FBI
is supposed to be doing something about
a crime and terrorism yet their biggest
ever investigation has been into the
capital Riot on January 6 which was bad
but in the context of things that are
wrong in this country it is really not
the worst thing to be looking at and yet
it seems that Nancy Pelosi Adam Schiff
Chuck Schumer sadly Joe Biden seemed to
be running the FBI and its priorities
right
well Miranda you characterized it as
potentially a fishing Expedition Shannon
bream said they have to have their next
steps in mind whatever it is I think
something is very clear the burden of
proof is going to be incredibly high on
the American institutions because the
electorate a large percentage of the
electorate are looking at this with a
great amount of jaundiced skepticism uh
Miranda great to talk to you this
evening
you too will all right you're looking
there on your screens at new pictures of
former president Trump leaving Trump
Tower in New York City tonight they're
on your screen just a moment ago as the
sun has set in New York City we turn now
uh to Joe Kent for reaction he's a
former Army Special Forces and he's
running for congress in the state of
Washington Joe it's great to have you
with us tonight
um year five I believe we are year six
basically from before Donald Trump's
election to tonight we have seen
investigation after investigation and
allegation after allegation do you think
tonight what we're looking at now will
be any different than the outcome of the
past six years or will it simply be
another illustration of the power of an
allegation
well it has to be different than what
we've seen before because we've seen the
complete and total weaponization of Our
National Security State you you
mentioned how this all began with the
russiagate Sham hoax and we saw the
National Security estate at the at the
highest levels weaponized against
President Trump and his campaign than
throughout his administration and now
with the narrative coming from January 6
and make no mistake this is where the
narrative really really was fortified to
turn these potent tools against not just
president Trump but many of his top
advisors people who aren't even on the
ground January 6 and then folks that
were put away thrown into essentially
political prisons without any kind of
due process and now the National
Security State continues to be on the
hunt against President Trump or and even
all the way down to you know parents
that show up to school board meetings so
we have to realize that we're at War
when we take back the house in 2023
bringing the National Security State to
heal must be our top priority any
Republican who is not ready for that
fight is unfit for Duty
you know Joe and I've mentioned this
several times tonight but I imagine if
you're seeing at home watching this
sense of uh it and and we heard earlier
on the program it's not simply
corruption it's just what we're watching
unfold in America isn't limited to as
you mentioned the National Security
State it's not limited to law
enforcement you I think very aptly Joe
pointed out school board meetings which
of course the doj classified those
parents as domestic terrorists but but
beyond that
censorship within big technology it it's
hard I would imagine for an American
citizen who doesn't subscribe to the
current thing whatever that that
political philosophy may be driving it
but whatever is the current thing all
right everybody I just was texting with
a friend of mine who was down in the
Palm Beach area and he indicated to me
he's monitoring uh police radio and he
says there is increa I don't know if
this is true this is but he told me he
says he is hearing increased law
enforcement chatter on police radio
about this Gathering that is now taking
place with the let's go Brandon flags
and the entire thing
in just the 15 minutes we've been
watching
the crowd here has increased in size
dramatically as you can see out front an
increased law enforcement presence no
evidence so far that anybody's getting
violent I mean because it's all trumpets
at least for now
and that's what we know so far but we
are monitoring all of it very very
closely and of course hopefully no one
ever will be hurt at any of this stuff
because that would be terrible
I want to say thank you to stinky
mcstains as well as Mr Potato Head and
blueberry babe for the twitch Prime
subscriptions
um let's listen to a couple other
voicemails from people that are coming
in
David sir
how much or how many bottles of uppers
do you think they're gonna find in
Mar-A-Lago during this raid yeah just
curious I don't know that's these these
are all really good questions really
really good questions
uh
let's see what else we have
people calling in
oh my God it's probably happening he's
getting ready to go I am excited this is
oh man I just keep he messed around and
he's finding out I love it I love it
people are really really excited about
this
um
now here is a more do you guys want to
hear a more
sort of sober reaction to this let's
listen to it
hey David I'm watching your coverage
right now the uh FBI raid on Mar-A-Lago
and obviously this is extremely
interesting but uh rather than a lot of
other uh people contacting you I'm not
feeling
super elated I mean obviously it's good
to see Trump potentially the uh of
accountable
but I'm feeling more uneasy and worried
about the potential for you know
right-wing violence of course we
obviously saw January 6th
and I mean that was you know I thought
of a stolen election and now you've got
the potential for Trump to be you know
held criminally accountable and then
potentially never be able to hold office
again I'm just worried I mean these
people are
extremely insane and you know have no
problem with violence and that I don't
know it's a very concerning
anyway uh keep up the great work love
your content listen those are completely
reasonable concerns I'm worried that
these people will become violent as well
uh I mean that listen they've proven
that they're willing to do violence
Taylor asks what do I think Trump's
Final Act of defiance will be incite the
mob directly I doubt he will go down
quietly oh no matter what happens
Trump's not going down quietly that's
for damn sure
the FBI found the 11 780 votes in the
safe I need 11
right right right right
um folks people are dumping in
memberships like we've never seen we're
setting a record here V just made a
patreon pledge those count double so
that puts us at 696.
um let's go for 750 and see if we can
get there the following people just
signed up Su chin
tendulker you know what that's a
reference to guys that's beautifully
done that's a reference to wait where do
I have these
uh here it is
no way
yeah suchin tendulker is a new member
Adam Johnson is a new member Eric
Carpenter has just signed up Henry Perez
and Kimberly O'Keefe are new members
also thanks to Kristen McClure who just
signed up
that is five putting us at 701 folks
it's sort of like the speed of light I
never thought we would break 700 but we
have
it's incredible I also want to thank
hold on where is this Kevin goncalo or
Gonzalo for the sign up at
joinpakman.com the coupon code is indict
if there were ever a day to sign up on
my website it would be today and one of
the member benefits is access to the
bonus show which Alex Jones despises oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad well I don't know
that Alex Jones is necessarily in the
position to be talking about what other
people are doing to make money at this
point in time but I would love to add
your name to the membership roles and
you can use the coupon code indict when
you sign up Mr says thanks for your work
over the years and for pushing back on
the torrent of lies that enabled Trump
and for correctly and repeatedly
identifying Maga as fascism will thank
you Mr let's see what the latest is here
from CNN beats 17 Acres he's hosted uh
International world leaders uh the the
Prime Minister of Japan had visited here
uh Shinzo Abe also the president of
China there are also many politicians
who have come here to Kiss the Ring
since he moved here full time to
Mar-A-Lago including Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis Marjorie Taylor green the
house Republican leader Kevin McCarthy
all coming here to visit the former
president at Mar-A-Lago John Randy K
racing to the scene for us in Palm Beach
thank you very much
other news now a Federal grand jury has
indicted a Russian national and accused
right so a lot a lot a lot happening and
we are monitoring the scene there at
Mar-A-Lago which just seems to continue
to build and build and build and we will
see what exactly happens there
um super chat's continuing to come in
what are the chances Trump has dirt on
some Republican members of Congress 100
percent
100 percent
eating popcorn watching this soon
switching to Wine well said H shy
David sir I'm curious you think Don Jr
prefers Pepsi or Coke I couldn't tell
you
I know nothing about soda
I haven't had a soda in 20 years
thank you to Honey Badger and eggs
Marshall as well as Frosty and Matt
Stein
hmm
I wonder if that's my friend Matt uh for
the twitch Prime subscriptions also
thanks to Zuzu pebbles for gifting five
that's nine total
702 plus 9 is 7 11.
7-Eleven
I'm worried but thrilled says amethyst
Jones fear can't stop the equal
application of Law and Order let's hope
not let's hope not because Fox News is
very very aggressively running
interference and they're gonna they will
believe listen they're already The
Narrative by tomorrow morning they're
all going to be on the same page this
was prosecutorial misconduct
partisan ordered by democrats crafted by
Biden
etc etc etc that's what it's going to be
and by tomorrow morning it's already
that
but they'll be organized around it by
tomorrow
that's the uh
they're making it abundantly clear
let's listen to another voicemail or two
about this hey David uh just following
up on another call
um there is zero percent chance they
don't find
145 bottles of Adderall followed by 145
um
uh bottles of Valium yeah lots of people
who use uppers then they need the
downers to be able to go to sleep that's
that's absolutely true that's absolutely
true
show here in California whoa
didn't realize we were gonna get a call
from the Andrew fox show today
and I am so excited I don't know what
that is by the way
and now with Trump getting raided this
is the most stoked I've been since it
got confirmed that that piece of [ __ ]
lost the election this is just a
fantastic day it was a great day at work
he closed a bunch of deals
I mean I'm in sales and then I got to do
the Trump's house is rated and this is
just a fantastic day and I'm glad we get
to share it with everybody thank you so
much David sir yeah everybody's in such
a good mood today it's wild it's wild
four more years of Biden thank God I
guys I don't even think Biden's running
for re-election I actually don't think
this has anything to do with with Biden
quite frankly wow no soda you should try
Coke Zero no calories or sugar no
negative effects I hope that's a joke
guys I hope that that's a joke doesn't
Coke Zero have aspartame
I don't want any of that stuff
Coke Zero has what is in Coke Zero
oh boy I don't know that I'm looking for
Coke Zero
carbonated water caramel color
phosphoric acid aspartame potassium
benzoate oh God natural flavors
potassium citrate
a sulfame potassium and it also has
phenylalanine
but it's got no sugar guys
I'm off benzoates I'm off aspartame
I'm out guys because of that I'm out no
Coke Zero for me
No Coke Zero for me
um thank you to both an anonymous gifter
as well as to absurdities each gifting
20 subscript each gifting 10
subscriptions on Twitch putting us at 7
31 also want to say thanks to peace
swerve sailcat grimalker
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 7 34 and then over on the
website there is something criminal
happening on the website
right now 81 people are somewhere in the
process of getting memberships and the
following have done so and now I'm going
to thank the Mitch Crossley Linda Clark
Brad Buchanan hold on where'd Brad go
there is
David krepp Mike
almost got me
almost got me Mike oh
wow I almost got you almost got me
Brianna Texas
um sundara mcwhirter Danica Calhoun
Sean Gomez
Wade Griffith
Henry farv Everett Brian Charles
Buchanan
Dustin Barnes
wow this is crazy Mike Deanna
Jason Harlow Cynthia Pruitt Elise Bowman
Brad Smith all signing up on my website
that's 15 putting us at 749 wow
whoever is member 750 I'll send you a
free item from my website let's listen
to Hannity triggered Biden's top
political rival that's the former
president of the United States of
America Donald Trump earlier today the
FBI raided the former president's
Florida home Mar-A-Lago while he was in
New York according to president Trump
the agent swarmed his residence
unannounced breaking into the home and
even his personal safe in a statement
the 45th president wrote quote my
beautiful home is currently Under Siege
rated and occupied by a large group this
is exactly what we've been waiting for
the Hannity reaction what happened to
the president of the United States
before after working and cooperating
with the relevant government agencies
this unannounced rate on my home was not
necessary or appropriate it is
prosecutorial misconduct the
weaponization of the justice system and
an attack by the radical left Democrats
who desperately do not want me to run
for president in 2024. according to the
New York Times tonight who got the scoop
first somehow the search was focused on
documents that the former president
brought with him from the White House
including potentially classified
documents sources are now telling Fox
News that the raid was not related in
any way way to January 6 but according
to One Source the FBI was quote not
being judicious about what they took
during the search just so we are clear
this raid is truly completely
unprecedented and you can't imagine this
what would have ever happened to a
Democrat this is where Americans now
begin to ask the question
dual justice system in America is there
Equal justice under the law do we have
equal applications of our laws all of a
sudden Hannity cares about that it's
never rated even though she stored
troves of classified material on a
personal server she deleted 33 000
emails remember nobody had ever heard a
bleach bit before Hillary Clinton and
then there were hammers involved with
with devices and SIM cards that were
missing how about the dirty unverifiable
Russian dossier that Hillary Clinton
paid for oh guys I didn't think he would
be this triggered this is unbelievable
today later we're president what about
the high-ranking doj officials that
signed what was says at the time top of
a fisa warrant verified what they signed
their name to something that was
unverifiable and has now been completely
debunked and claimed before judges that
it wasn't take a breath it wasn't and
then there's Joe Biden on tape the real
quid pro quo bragging that he withheld a
billion taxpayer dollars you have six
hours uh to fire a Ukrainian prosecutor
that is not at all what happened not
even close to what happened being paid
millions of dollars with no experience
at all whatsoever this has been all one
sentence the last three minutes happened
a hunter nothing what if it was Don Jr
what if it was Eric Trump on tape you
have uh of course Hunter Biden smoking
crack and with hookers I think those
things are illegal what happened to him
nothing we had director Ray uh before
Congress last week they have had Hunters
I thought the last guy was good this is
the absolute best millions of dollars
paid to Hunter from Ukraine Russia he
must have used the right wing random
word generator to write this monologue
100 000 dollar shopping spree with a
with a Chinese National no experience
nothing happens Joe on tape bragging
again and again I've never ever ever
discussed my son's foreign business
dealings well we know of at least 14
occasions now and we have pictures in
some cases with Joe Hunter and guess
what Hunter's Farm business partners
nothing happens to them the bidens have
never had their homes rated they
literally sold access to the highest
levels of our government the big guy was
taking his 10 cut according to his own
son's laptop
he squeezed in two conspiracies there
the big guy and the hunter laptop into
half a sentence I've never seen Hannity
this triggered we'll ever get charged
with any crime no raid to his house but
if your last name is Roger Stone or if
your name is Paul manafort you got a
pre-dawn raid guns drawn FBI SWAT team
pointing guns in your face
a process crime there's never been a
criminal Administration like this one of
course the aftermath is unprecedented
borrow you get put in handcuffs and leg
shackles and hauled away from an airport
he's still going we're in charge of a
misdemeanor we saw the same heavy-handed
tactics with General Flynn Carter page
Paul manafort pre-dawn raid guns drawn
and so many others make no mistake if
you're associated with Donald Trump in
any way you better cross all your eyes
and Dot all your t's because they're
coming for you with the full force of
the federal government they will break
down your front door they will Spire in
your text and your phone calls they will
charge you with every process
and handcuffs and they'll stick guns in
your face at 5 30 in the morning
why doesn't this ever happen to a
Democrat equal justice under the law is
it dead equal application of our laws is
that dead as our department of justice
been turned into a political weapon and
if they can do this to president Trump
from what do you think they could do to
the rest of us we'll have full Breaking
coverage all night long here now with
more Fox News legal analyst Greg Jarrett
Harvard Law oh they're bringing on
dershowitz oh it's too much guys they're
bringing on dershowitz dershowitz
recently complained that he can't speak
at the Martha's Vineyard Library anymore
because they don't like them there this
is this is going to be unbelievable I
can't but I'm so glad I'm here to
witness this live so I said they were on
you know they were going through uh they
said they're willing to give all those
things back
um why didn't they just say um can we
come over and take a look at
what you have and make sure that there's
no classified documents here just like
why didn't they say to Peter Navarro
he's still going to attorney have your
client report at 8 am at this location
or Paul manafort or Roger Stone uh why
the Big Show only when it's a
conservative because it's Donald Trump
and this is the weaponization for
political purposes by the FBI and the
Department of Justice you're right Sean
when you identify the presidential
records act of 1968 a 78 Which is far
from a model of clarity and in fact it's
one of the more opaque laws this is what
they call Legal analysis
um we're going to get back to this as
soon as dershowitz speaks I can't wait
to hear what he says thanks to Brandon
and Chewie each for gifting five
subscriptions over on
um YouTube but number 750 getting the
free item is Thomas romack Thomas us
please email info
davidpakman.com to collect your free
item folks we may be able
to actually breach the number 800 today
which we've never been able to do so
before to quote
um uh George Bush let me see how many
folks I can thank before they go to
dershowitz analysis which I don't want
to miss Sun Sandra Ramos Janice Gerke
Clarence Page is a new member RR Megan
Osborne Ben who almost got me with a
fake crass and crude fake name Matthew
Henderson Joey Kinney Lori cadizone
uh let's actually not Lori no I'll get
back to Lori Tina Parsons Brian Howe all
of these people signing up on my website
some talukdar
Melissa parzo
someone going by the name fetus okay uh
Christopher Matheson
Cole Stewart Deborah Giles John Miller
Soma
Ross belsum all signing up on my website
very much appreciated it was 19 putting
us at 779. let's listen to the great
Alan dershowitz deliver his analysis
tied into his socks and walked out with
those documents but then everybody in
the media every Democrat he was just
sloppy very sloppy as he shoved it down
his pants he was sloppy you know he
didn't mean to take them with him
um and everybody bought that excuse so
this therein brings up the double
standard issue what are your thoughts
well definitely there is a double
standard we've seen so many instances of
allegedly classified material being a
compromise the key point that
everybody's missing here is that Donald
Trump was not in Mar-A-Lago so there was
no reason not to issue a subpoena
returnable tomorrow so that there's no
claim that Trump could have destroyed
anything this should have been a
subpoena not a search warrant if it is a
search warrant it has to have a high
level of cause demonstrating that the
evidence would have been destroyed not
only that you don't think that there's
people at Mar-A-Lago
who might know to destroy evidence if
they were raided I mean this is just
it's such speculation from dershowitz
all assuming that everything was done
completely wrong when there is no such
evidence violated the rules of the
justice department they have gone after
both a four we know people around Trump
were complicit in destroying documents
because Trump would throw them in bags
and then someone else would burn them so
we know that other people were complicit
in the destruction of evidence single
standard it's not good enough you don't
get a warrant unless a subpoena won't
suffice in a democratic rule of law
country you do it legitimately you go to
the lawyer you say by tomorrow I want
that safe delivered to the justice
department I want these documents turned
over and unless you can demonstrate that
there was a give them 12 hours to take
out whatever they want from can you
imagine hey tomorrow you have got to
bring us the safe oh right and we won't
touch anything that's in the safe even
things that are incriminating yeah we'll
just bring you the safe the way it is
right now just trust us I guess what
everybody's wondering especially in
light of what we went through for three
years Greg at some point when do you say
the abuse of power the corruption the
The Witch Hunt to quote a famous
best-selling book
um that this is focused on one man and
one man only and a whole double standard
exists and nobody else has ever held
accountable for either the exact law
similar sets of circumstances I know it
was different with Comey but similar uh
the same with Hillary the 33 000 emails
all right so they're coping pretty hard
as you can see there is like a
full-fledged standout happening outside
Mar-A-Lago now people with a trump flag
where Trump is kissing an American flag
which he did at CPAC a couple of years
ago even though it is after 9 pm on the
East Coast this is building into a
full-fledged Trump rally and it's all
because Trump's Mar-A-Lago was raided if
you are just joining us welcome if
you're watching on Twitch make sure to
follow the twitch channel it's free and
it's beautiful if you're watching on
YouTube leave a comment letting me know
whether you believe an indictment is
coming yes or no
make sure to like the stream and make
sure you're subscribed to my YouTube
channel all of these things are
completely and totally free and I want
to hear from you and it's all crazy it's
all crazy what's going on
um
let's get to a couple of other
voicemails that are coming in
um
about this let's see
what some of these are a bit too long
but let's see here
David sir any reports that they are take
toilets Gallardo and also need to get
some prints for some of
oh terrible terrible audio that's that
was it could have been funny but it was
bad audio thanks to shorty blueberry
babe oh lydius do you grock and little
ratacopter just gifted five
subscriptions toad Mountain Oasis and
one eye dead grabbing subscriptions as
well that puts us at 792 folks we may be
about to breach 800 which we have never
done
the following people just signed up on
my website many using the coupon code
indict you can also use the coupon code
Obama Obama
Karen Siegel Scott fullbirth
Megan Snipes Brandon Parvin Catherine
Hall Stephen Maccabee
um all signing up on my website that is
six putting us at 798
also want to say thanks to people
gifting subscriptions Stanley minarik is
one such person Laurie catazone is
another Kimberly cerniglia
is another and I really appreciate those
gifts folks that's putting us at 801
could we couldn't possibly make it to
900 memberships in a day the previous
record was 605 it seems inconceivable
that that would happen
and yet faceplant just gifted five and
webtech and November just signed up
which puts us at 808
and then Adrian marillo signed up on my
website putting us at 809. I don't think
we can do it
but why don't we try as things becoming
increasingly frenetic
outside of Mar-A-Lago the site where
today they were in Trump's bedroom
apparently they were in his private
quarters they opened his safe they may
be uh um suctioned the toilet to see
what was going on there
oh they're speaking to Eric trumple
let's see a lot of money and go and
actually fight for this country for the
first time and he did a better job than
anybody has ever done and they started
coming after him the Washington Post the
day he won 2016 the day he won November
8th that night they wrote an article
this is when impeachment begins he was
in prison he hadn't been elected for
Less you know for five minutes at that
point and they started this is when
impeachment begins and then he's
impeached the first time and then he was
impeached a second time and they
slandered him they belittled him you
know they went after him they went after
all of us there's no family in American
history that has taken more arrows in
the back
than the Trump family every single time
and you know what it's gone on past
politics you look at more than the
families who have had people killed by
mass shootings more than the families
that have been destroyed by the
incarceration of just people who have
drugs these are the biggest victims
folks the Trump family can a person The
History of the United States every
single day we get another subpoena and
they do it for one reason because they
don't want Donald Trump to run and win
again in 2024 and Sean that's what this
is about today to have 30 FBI agents
actually more than that descend on
Mar-A-Lago give absolutely you know no
notice go through the gate start
ransacking an office ransacking a closet
you know they broke into a safe he
didn't even have anything in the safe I
mean right there was nothing in there
coming from what the National Archives
yet you know Hunter Biden he's a
Firearms crime prostitution illegal
drugs
um you know Shady deals with everybody
around the world and by the way it's all
on his laptop for the whole world to see
these people are so triggered
cooperated by everybody where are these
FBI agents where where is everybody why
is it that the arrows only fly at Donald
Trump and his family why is it that the
political persecution only goes one way
in this country
well let's talk a little bit about what
you were being told what was the purpose
for this raid here we go
Sean the purpose of the raid from what
they said was because the National
Archives wanted to you know cooperate uh
whether or not Donald Trump had any
documents in his possession and my
father has worked so collaboratively
with them for months in fact the lawyer
that's been working on this was totally
shocking because I had such an amazing
relationship with these people and all
of a sudden I know notice they sent you
know 20 cars and and 30 agents Sean I
mean this this is just more political
persecution this is the best Donald J
Trump Facebook it's possible nothing
will come of this but seeing these
people so triggered is really a reward
in and of itself believing the White
House I don't know I'm guessing that
your dad probably didn't pack a single
box I'm just guessing you would know
better than I you can tell me if he did
or if he didn't all these boxes all this
all your personal items someone else
wrote down a Mar-A-Lago there's someone
else's fault guys be classified
information that had been written about
a long time ago let's walk through the
process so
Mar-A-Lago the people that work for your
dad were working with the National
Archives to go through the material to
make sure if there was anything
mistakenly taken that it was going to be
returned and you were working
collaborative Trump would clog toilets
with documents and were supposed to
believe that he's never handling
anything as you effectively you know six
hours to move out of the White House
it's it's effectively inauguration time
where one president gets moved out and
one president gets moved in right that's
how the whole system works is as you
know better than anybody my father
always kept clippings
um you know press clippings you'd have
you know newspaper articles pictures
notes from us when my mom passed away a
couple weeks ago you know he still had
all the the notes uh you know over the
years they've been saved all the notes
that she had ever written him I mean
it's a beautiful thing my father saves
clippings and things like that so he had
he had boxes right when he moved out of
the White House and he was very
collaborative you want to search for
anything if you think anything like you
know come right ahead I mean it was it
was an Open Door or policy and all of a
sudden 30 agents descend upon Mar-A-Lago
Sean this didn't come from the local FBI
field office in uh in Palm Beach Florida
you know who this came from this came
from one place and one building and and
that is the White House in Washington DC
there is absolutely no evidence of that
maybe evidence for that is forthcoming
but there is no evidence of that folks
this is really crazy but we just got
another 100 subscription gift from s
Prez on Twitch
1 000 memberships in a day is now in
play it has never been in play before
and we may already be very close let's
tie it let's see if we can tally William
McClellan just gifted five on YouTube so
that puts us at 9 14.
on Twitch I want to thank tune DBZ triby
Deb in Michigan
e-call
cusmane
collio preacher Lil neezy of course Lil
neezy uh that's seven more that puts us
at 9 21.
now that's not all because there are
things happening on the website as well
um
lucianne Cole
Daniel chavaro John Gibson
Pete brisolara
Arthur Daddario Christopher Motes
Richard Clifford Brent silk smooth silk
Braun Anderson Max Bush Christopher
Escobar
uh Matthew Neves Anna Lopez
Isadora Simon have all signed up on the
website
now that puts us at 9 31 and then I have
people gifting subscriptions people like
Anthony webb
Stanley minarik
Jason sickmeyer
and that's three putting us at 9 34. it
is plausible that we could hit a
thousand
Captain Damon and creamy have signed up
Bobby Doon has signed up and then Shield
Anvil has gifted five that puts us at 9
42.
I don't even know that we can fit a
thousand I think it maxes at a thousand
as Eric Trump continues to rant the
police situation continues to grow just
outside Mar-A-Lago
let's listen to the analysis on CNN
briefly and kick off that afternoon if
it hasn't already but I do want to make
one point we didn't a lot of the reason
that we didn't see you know in uh
indictments uh potentially uh or other
aspects of Investigations in these
previous instances was because he was a
sitting president and he's not a sitting
president now and so you know there you
don't the the olc justice department
legal opinion says you can't indict a
sitting president and Mueller decided
not to test that
um he's not a president anymore and I
think that you know you have seen him
struggle with that struggle with being
out of office and what that looks like
I'll say he does not have that
protection and a lot of people around
him a lot of people close to him are
very blunt and open that they believed
part of the reason that he was running
for president and there were there are
many that he will run if he does run he
loses the attention if he doesn't run he
loses the ability to fundraise if he
doesn't run but he also gains a
potential Shield against prosecution and
and people should not underestimate that
as a motivating Merrick Garland said
running would not be a shield for Trump
get elected and not get charged so
Alyssa you're you're around you have
been around
um all of the people that were around
him are you hearing from them are you
hearing anything from them are you
seeing what they're saying and and what
are they saying about this well my
world's a bit disconnected from them
personally now but what I am seeing is
kind of a standard light party line from
the folks still close to the former
president which is this is a Witch Hunt
this is Biden and Democrats coming after
him the you know Democratic Department
of Justice not the independent hand of
the FBI
um and there's a very quick narrative
that's been spun and I would know you
know Fox News it's it's night and day
what you're hearing on other news
outlets in his preferred news Outlet
which is framing it only one way that
this is a Witch Hunt and attack on the
former president so half the country's
hearing a very different conversation
than the one that we're having here well
only a few million people watch Fox so
to say that three million people is half
the country it is a bit of a stretch
Alyssa to play out and you can guarantee
that nobody is going to do that in
general especially when you look
all right I'm told that there is more
action on Truth sensual under Donald
Trump's account let's take a look
uh uh no there is not actually he has
not posted anything additional folks I
think we're about to hit a thousand new
members today let me see here Lucifer
Chelsea mooncat surely you can't be
serious gifted five my name is Jeff V
signal is seven Titan gifted five making
it 12. green apples and Patch Howard
makes it 14. blueberry babe cap bones
Bobby Dune
uh put us at 17.
that's 9 59.
uh
over on the website
Aaron ash oh God hold on the website's
scrolling too quickly Danny Apperson and
Aaron Ash Amalia Weber
as well as Troy Roselle have signed up
Brent Tripp is a new member Alan wax has
signed up Casey chafalo is a new member
Michael Aranda Francisco Resto sure
Sanders and Josh Bradford our new
members as well as Angelica Daviston
that is another 10 putting us at
9.69 and then a couple gifted
subscriptions from Shireen Smith as well
as Alexandra Zahn Brienne Cochrane
um that is three which pushes us to 972.
it is in play here guys a thousand is in
play spades KY Dizzle Mickey's ghost
dogmatic and Charles Weiland push us on
Twitch to 977.
if you want a free subscription on the
website go to davidpackman.com free
membership
we may be getting to a thousand tonight
it's conceivable
um Brennan Hilliard just signed up on
the website putting us at 9.78. Anthony
webb
just gifted a subscription putting us at
9.79 I don't even know that this is
allowed to be perfectly honest
Courtney just gifted five on YouTube
putting us at 984.
uh let me see what else we have here
my name is Jeff gifted10 putting us at
9.94.
omusa steelhorn and Big Fat Pat
push us to 996.
could this be happening Brian Lang
signing up on the website is number 997
folks I think we're gonna do it
who will be number
one thousand
on the day of a raid at Mar-A-Lago
the people cannot believe it
Bill Dickhouse gifting a membership on
the website is number 998
[Music]
oh
uh and then thank you to hold on let me
make sure I get the right person here
because I don't want to miss this
Shield Anvil just gifted 10 ladies and
gentlemen putting us at 1008 and Then
followed by coffee fish
lifttronic Lassie pushed me Jen here
kaporter so grind screw scamander KY
dizzle gyps
Joe Dies at the End Lenny Rudy Pedraza
is 12 putting us at a thousand twenty
folks They're Gonna Cancel my Twitch
account
they are not going to let us stream on
YouTube with this going on
I just know they're not going to do it
and then even more memberships dumping
in Donald Works polis Carrie as well as
uh who are these people James malpas and
Larry Vulcan
Mr Butters has signed up that's pretty
serious uh that is like a thousand
twenty four the website's quite
literally about to crash there's 199 now
202 people in the process of signing up
I don't know that we've ever had 200
people on the website it's not even
clear it can handle it to be perfectly
Frank
uh let's get back to the crazy Fox news
coverage and see what's going on I'll
try to keep up with the numbers
interrupting you I think it's important
that we get an answer to this would it
be normal practice to send Washington
field office agents when you have Miami
Field office agents which are much
closer to Mar-A-Lago
it can be normal in this respect that
the Washington field office may have
more evidence about the case may know
more what they're looking for can do a
more targeted rate so that's not
necessarily the thing the fact that the
investigation originates with an office
that is currently dealing with political
uh tampering allegations and it's very
important when Chris Ray was asked about
this he said he found what his office
did was very deeply troubling not
troubling enough to stop the agents from
raiding the president today
well connected to the Whistleblower that
Charles Grassley was talking about last
week that's right that's that it's those
allegations that Chris Ray was reacting
to he called those allegations very
troubling he removed all right so Fox
continuing to run interference according
to sources telling me that and my
colleague Gabby Orr but then after he
left that the two attorneys that were
meeting with these investigators at
Mar-A-Lago then took them to a room that
is in the basement of Mar-A-Lago there
and showed them where the boxes of
documents that were taken from Trump's
time in the White House were being
stored we are told that these
investigators looked around the room
then they left and I am told by a person
who attended that meeting that five days
later
Trump's attorneys got a letter from one
of those investigators asking them to
further secure the documents and the
room where these documents were being
stored I'm told it was locked but they
asked them to further enhance that
security essentially and that led
Trump's aides to then put a padlock on
this door where these documents were
being stored and that really just gives
insight into the fact that there have
been discussions between investigators
and the former president's attorneys in
the lead-up to this search warrant being
executed now of course June 8th that was
two months ago today so what happened in
those eight weeks that led this from
going from investigators visiting
mar-a-longo to then of course this
search warrant being executed that is
still a gap that remains to be filled it
remains to be seen what exactly was
happening there but it does shed light
and some insight into what was happening
in the lead-up to this and it appears to
be part of what Trump was referencing in
his statement today confirming Sarah
that the raid had happened where he
talked about how he had been cooperating
with these officials about this and so
there are still a lot of big questions
of course coming out of this major
development tonight but it does shed
light on a meeting a rare meeting that
investigators had with Trump's Attorneys
at Mar-A-Lago two months ago can I just
quickly ask you Caitlyn just to clarify
Trump's own attorneys showed these
investigators where there were some
documents and then the investigators
asked them to
secure those documents padlock the door
or however they wanted to secure them is
that that's the the sequence of things
yeah I don't I don't think that they
specifically said you need to put a
padlock on the door but I was told that
days later after those investigators had
left Mar-A-Lago they sent a letter to
Trump's attorneys asking them to further
enhance the security for these documents
regarding these documents and of course
part of this major investigation is to
is into whether or not that included
classified information potentially and
so you can understand why they would
want them to be secured that is
obviously a number one priority and why
things like the presidential records act
exist but it does show that there were
conversations between the two sides
about what was happening what documents
are being stored what documents they
were exactly remains to be seen I think
the other notable part about this is
that Trump did stop by this meeting that
his attorneys were having with
investigators we were told he simply
greeted them and then went on but he was
at the property at the time of this
visit happening in June at Mar-A-Lago
can I quickly ask you can you clarify
whether or not the White House the the
Biden White House knew that this was
happening today that there was going to
be an FBI search of former president's
home
it's a major development and there are
big questions about who at the White
House was aware of this if anyone was
aware we are told that most officials
were not aware of this that they found
out when everyone else found out today
when Trump confirmed that yes this raid
had happened of course major questions
for whether or not President Biden
himself knew we don't have reporting on
that front specifically and we've also
reached out to the justice department to
comment on this they have not done so
yet clearly this is an active
investigation but that has been a major
question as well all right Caitlin
Collins thank you so much for bringing
us the latest update on this huge news
we are again joined by former Federal
prosecutor Shan Wu incredible this may
be all the news that we are going to be
getting today uh oh wait no new video of
the raid let's see eat them at the polls
in November the answer to this is get a
house Republican House a Republican
Senate and let's rip the corruption not
just in the FBI but across the whole
system let's rip the corruption out but
I have to tell you I couldn't believe it
I think this video on the left is not
video of the raid I think this is live
video right now of Mar-A-Lago I actually
don't think that's video of the raid
necessary
and it's it's clearly an effort design I
think partly to go to president Trump in
the hopes that he will do something that
will further validate the left's fantasy
about the kind of guy he is the fact is
he did nothing wrong he's cooperated and
for his trouble and you just heard Eric
say this the the Trump family has been
persecuted more than any presidential
family in history and they've also done
the most insane stuff to a former and
potentially future president
what can they do to you or your cousin
or your friends or your neighbors and I
think it's a very scary step towards a
police state eliminating the
Constitution as a mute is vile
the police state is Trump sending
National Guard to cities to stop
peaceful protests like he dreams of
doing that's the police state not what
is obviously an investigation where they
crossed every T and dotted every eye
unless we hear or learn otherwise an
airport to humiliate the individual for
a misdemeanor I would argue the same for
a process crime in the case of manafort
or Roger Stone
certainly a message was sent here but
here's where the double standard comes
in this this is why Hunter Biden is
important this is why Hillary Clinton's
33 000 email deletions are open no this
is why the dirty dossier is important
this is why
um lying on fisa applications are
important if I ever lie to a judge I
think I'd be taken out in handcuffs and
shackles too this is why what Sandy
Berger did is important now America has
a right to ask okay why did you do this
because I can't conceive of what would
warrant the Attorney General of the
United States and the FBI director to
well it doesn't matter whether Sean
Hannity does or doesn't understand it
that's the thing he seems to be unable
to understand all right everybody we are
going to be covering this tomorrow on
the podcast and we will have Clips we
will have everything if you uh I
appreciate everybody who joined me today
make sure that you're following us on
Twitch and subscribed on YouTube both of
those things are free and you'll just be
notified when I go live again this is
one of the biggest stories and I have a
feeling there's going to be much much
more here uh tomorrow
um huge day in terms of new subscribers
uh memberships and whatnot we're
probably at 1100 I've lost track because
there was such a dumping of memberships
right when we got to a thousand it's
been a real pleasure being here with all
of you fine folks today so make sure
you're following on Twitch make sure
you've liked on Facebook make sure that
you have subscribed on YouTube I think
like 2 thousand additional people
subscribed on YouTube during the stream
and I am going to see everybody again
very very soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Trump's White House toilet
be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
[Music]
ten times